how many times have you heard this
classic tale some sort of apocalypse
wreaks havoc on our planet and before
you know it all the people are gone
except for this guy the last man on
earth he somehow manages to run into the
last woman on earth they decide that
it's up to them to save the human race
so they start making babies and soon
enough the earth is repopulated and
everyone lives happily ever after but is
that even possible
what kind of awkward problems would be
involved and why would our new
population be so different this is what
if and here's what would happen if you
had to repopulate the planet
repopulating an entire planet would be
no easy feat in this scenario assuming
the two remaining people are actually
fertile the first generation of this new
population would all be brothers and
sisters and the second would be cousins
if the world's new population is just a
product of inbreeding does it even stand
a chance so our last couple on earth has
as many babies as they possibly can
that's fine but we can't stop there I
mean that's nice for a family picnic but
we're trying to repopulate the world
here taking the next step means that all
their kids now have to have babies with
each other in order to understand just
how deadly that is let's have a little
lesson in genetics we all have two
copies of every gene one from each
parent some of these copies can be bad
genes that carry genetic disorders
carrying these variants on their own
isn't a problem as long as we only have
one copy in fact most people watching
right now are carrying one or two
genetic variants that could be deadly if
we're born with an identical pair of
these variants that's when we run into
trouble and if our parents are brother
and sister their genes are much more
likely to be similar as more and more
relatives in breed the chances of their
offspring receiving identical copies of
bad genes and being born disabled or
diseased keeps increasing that doesn't
spell good news for the future of
humanity but if we have as many children
as possible odds are that some of them
will come out healthy right sure but
what happens when this inbreeding
continues over hundreds of years
for that answer all we have to do is
look at the European royalty of the past
for centuries European royal families
would intermarry to keep the power
within their ranks and that quickly led
to problems the biggest victim of this
was charles ii of spain who after
generations of interbreeding had less
genetic diversity than he would have if
his parents had been siblings as a
result he was born with a slew of
physical and mental disabilities he
couldn't walk until he was 8 years old
and his impotence led to the end of the
very dynasty his ancestors were trying
to preserve alright so we get it
interbreeding is bad but what if we
introduced a couple more people to help
with the repopulation would that work
not really because our small group of
people would become vulnerable to
something called the founder effect in a
small isolated population obscure and
harmful traits become common because the
founder population limits the number of
possible genetic combinations even if
they survive all the other fun that a
post-apocalyptic world has to offer
odds are that the founding members genes
would eventually combine to pass down
some sort of deadly condition to the
children and with medical care being a
thing of the past
the new humanity would probably only
last a couple of generations but hey
don't give up hope yet because history
shows that several small groups of
survivors have managed to grow and beat
the odds of genetics maybe it would be
possible to recover from the apocalypse
what would our new society look like
maybe our entire planet would speak the
same language or have the same
government but that's a topic for
another what-if
[Music]